my name is red wah I'm sorry
I'm a professor in behavioral ecology at
the University of Natal so I was
following a grouper and all of a sudden
it turned towards the reef and I saw the
head of a moray eel sticking out of a
crevice and I thought actually they
would start fighting now who is the
dominant predator in the reef but to my
big surprise the Moray Eel actually left
its crevice and they swam off together
side by side and after 5 metres or so
the more you started moving through
crevices while the grouper was clearly
waiting outside and so it was very
obvious that they hunt together so
groupers have two ways of signaling the
standard ways that the moray eel is in a
crevice and the group approaches and
then it shakes its head in rapid
succession and this is the signal come
on let's hunt the moray eel sneaks
through crevices and so the best way for
the prey to escape a moray eel list to
swim into the blue but in the blue
that's where the groupers and so by
coordinating the action they make sure
that it's not safe for the prey nicer
inside nor outside and that's how they
both increase their hunting success the
other signal is even more exciting and
this is when the group are typically
hands on its own and the prey escapes
into a crevice and then the grouper does
the equivalent of a human pointing
gesture that makes a head stance and
points towards the place where the prey
is hiding and this then attracts the
partner moray eel and hopefully for the
grouper flash to prey out again we got
very excited about the field results and
we decided to take the system from the
field to the lab and conduct controlled
experiments we constructed an artificial
reef and we also laminated in the
picture of Maury and attached it to
strings and the right thing to do was
that if the prey was above the coral the
groupers had to strike immediately and
if the prey was hiding below the coral
then the right thing to do was to go
there
actly towards the more ill and as a
reward the grouper would be thrown a
piece of food in the second part of the
experiment we had two moray eel models
and the challenge in this experiment was
for the groupers to identified it as one
competent and one incompetent moray eel
partner and therefore develop preference
for the competent partner and the speed
of learning and also the precision of
their choices equals data published on
chimpanzees in a similar experiment the
results clearly showed that fish are
able to perform rather complex behaviors
that they have an amazing repertoire to
solve their daily problems and hence
that they are certainly much smarter
than you might have thought